all right welcome everybody we continue
to try to
on the daily show the podcast etc bring
you
sort of the latest news normally this is
not a program where if we wait 90
minutes we might have something
different to report to you but because
ballots are still being counted in a
number of
key states in the presidential election
and there are even things still
happening
at the senate level and house level um
we're trying to figure out how to bring
you the latest information at whatever
time we do it and at this point in time
we do have changes to report to you from
where we were yesterday
no winner has yet been declared in the
presidential election between donald
trump and joe biden now i'm going to get
to the vote counts and to the scenarios
momentarily
but what you must understand is that
all of our worst worries about how
donald trump would react have happened
we covered some of them yesterday and we
will cover some more of them today
donald trump of course declaring victory
late tuesday early wednesday 2 a.m
saying we've won
yesterday donald trump and eric trump
and rudy giuliani and others
saying on twitter we won pennsylvania
pennsylvania has not yet been called and
the margin it continues to shrink
away from donald trump's favor and in
joe biden's favor
although trump still leads and i will
show you what those numbers are
and the latest which we will also be
covering today extensively is that
the trump campaign now claims to be
filing multiple lawsuits in various
states
in some states we know that they've
actually filed them in others they've
said they are filing them although we
don't actually know
and we have heard from joseph r biden jr
as well joe biden giving a short but
very appropriate and quite frankly very
presidential speech in wilmington
delaware yesterday so we are going to be
covering that
all of that being said let's now get
into the numbers and again
i am going to do a screen share with you
guys this seemed to work well
uh yesterday and give us um a pretty
good sense
of uh of of what is going on so let's
start there
first and foremost what has changed
since yesterday
wisconsin has been called for joe biden
with a less than one percent margin of
victory
donald trump says he has filed for a
recount there
and is emailing supporters asking for
money to fund
that recount michigan has also been
called
for joe biden and in fact as we get
slightly updated numbers literally as
we're speaking
michigan now about two and a half 2.7
points in favor of joe biden
a a bigger margin of victory in both
michigan and wisconsin actually
wisconsin is basically the same margin
of victory that trump had over hillary
in 2016
a larger margin of victory for joe biden
in michigan this year
than what donald trump had over hillary
clinton in 2016.
what is still oh before we go any
further alaska has still not been called
although we know it will go for donald
trump currently leading two to one
almost with half the vote reporting
they're just slow to count there a lot
of rural areas but we're going to
continue tracking and following that of
course but
in my count i am already giving those
three electoral votes to donald trump
in the meantime arizona is a source of
some controversy and later in today's
program
i'm going to bring you video of a trump
supporters gathering at the capitol in
phoenix arizona
and then sort of moving over and joining
another protest at the maricopa county
election center i believe it's called
where they are demanding that
they count the vote and they are mad at
fox news because not only the associated
press
which is what what we are using here but
also fox news
um called arizona although there are
people who feel it is still too close
with 88
reporting joe biden is up by 2.4 there
about 68 and a half thousand
votes so what does the race hinge on
if we grant joe biden arizona which
most but not all currently do it hinges
on the states of nevada pennsylvania
north carolina and georgia and again
conceding arizona to joe biden would put
him at 264 electoral votes
meaning a win in any of these four
outstanding states
and joe biden would be the next
president of the united states
the least likely for me is north
carolina
north carolina now the the vote count
has not actually moved for a full
24 hours we are not exactly sure why but
north carolina
is stuck at 94 percent reporting the
lead for donald trump right now
is about 1.4 percentage points which is
equal to about
80 000 votes i am not counting on north
carolina flipping
to joe biden following that
joe biden is currently leading in nevada
now the vote count in nevada yesterday
stopped being updated relatively early
and it had joe biden up seven tenths of
a point
that lead has now expanded as nevada
again this is as of this moment
as nevada has gone back to counting and
reporting votes
joe biden's lead has gone from seven
tenths of a point
to nine tenths of a point the path for
biden to win
is that a majority an important amount
of the remaining votes
are from the vegas area which went for
hillary clinton in 2016
anticipating it would go for joe biden
now that's the
argument for nevada with those six
electoral votes
joe biden would get to 270 presuming
nothing changes in arizona which has
been called
we then have the very curious case of
pennsylvania
and to explain what's happening in
pennsylvania
um understand that this was the
red mirage scenario state
pennsylvania does not start counting
mail-in ballots until the polls
close on election day pennsylvania
expected to have
favorable numbers for trump in in-person
voting favorable numbers for joe biden
in vote by mail and indeed on election
night
donald trump had a lead of eight even
nine or ten points
thinking back to different moments on
election night and over time that lead
started to shrink
yesterday when i came to you joe biden
was down about
seven points in pennsylvania and now
as the vote has been counted as you can
see here with this very interesting
chart from the new york times that i'm
showing people as the vote count has
gone
trump's biggest lead was right at about
55
as the vote count has increased it has
narrowed narrowed narrowed
now considered 1.8 points
by the new york times and officially
according to the associated press
also 1.8 points separating donald trump
and joe biden
that is about 116 000 vote lead for
trump
the path here for biden if you believe
there is one
is that there are a bunch of ballots
from pittsburgh which cannot even
legally be counted until tomorrow
and that as the philadelphia votes
continue to be counted the margins will
continue to shrink for donald trump and
maybe flip to joe biden of course
if joe biden wins pennsylvania he wins
the election we then have
georgia as you can see in georgia also
donald trump's biggest lead coming right
around 33 percent of the vote being
counted
from that point forward as more and more
of the vote has been counted
donald trump's lead has shrunk and
shrunk and shrunk
to the point that his lead is now a mere
0.3 percentage points
or about 13 500 votes
we have 99 reporting in georgia
so the at this point i don't even want
to go into the various models claiming
to know
how likely is it that it would go one
way how likely is it that it would go
the other way it's extraordinarily close
and if indeed it is the atlanta ballot
that remains
out it could get even closer
and maybe joe biden could win it or
maybe not so it is now down to these
four states now it goes without saying
as i pull up the map uh if we give
arizona
to joe biden as the associated press has
done
uh oh sorry and utah of course is a
trump state um as i mentioned earlier
even though officially alaska has not
been called for donald trump
i am calling it for donald trump because
it will ultimately go for donald trump
if joe biden were to win nevada that
would put him at 270 electoral votes and
this would be over
barring of course recounts and lawsuits
which donald trump is
doing if joe biden were to flip
pennsylvania
that would put him at 284 electoral
votes also 270
above 270 and it would secure this
election
if georgia were to flip to joe biden
that would put him at 280 electoral
votes
again securing a an electoral victory
and if north carolina flips to joe biden
that would also put him at 279 although
i i believe north carolina is the
least likely to flip so we the range of
scenarios that are remaining are
if trump wins all four of these states
trump wins re-election with 274
electoral votes imagine that arizona
were wrong
that could put donald trump at 285. if
arizona stays with biden
the best biden could do if he were to
get all four remaining states nevada
pennsylvania north carolina and georgia
it would put joe biden at 321 electoral
votes
i don't think there's any way that biden
gets a north carolina so for me the
biggest
real possibility for biden would be 306
i don't particularly think he gets
georgia either
and so if biden were to get nevada and
pennsylvania
joe biden would win with 290 my
prediction was
295 so that could be very very close
without nevada joe biden would have 284
with nevada instead of pennsylvania joe
biden would have exactly 270 electoral
votes and if that is the case
the proportional apportionment in
nebraska
could be the difference maker joe biden
got one electoral vote from the second
district in nebraska
if indeed this comes down to nevada and
joe biden doesn't get pennsylvania
doesn't get georgia doesn't get north
carolina
biden will have 270 thanks to that
one vote from nebraska without it
it could be the 269 to 269 tie scenario
we've been talking about
with it and nevada joe biden would win
270 to 268.
we may know more by tonight we may know
more by tomorrow
again checking in on the latest numbers
in pennsylvania with the latest update
still a 1.8 percentage point lead for
donald trump as votes are being counted
in georgia a 0.3 percent lead
for donald trump with 99 reporting
and in nevada with 76 reporting and more
vote expected there today
a lead of 0.9 percent
for joe biden in the state of nevada now
i don't even want to get
ahead of myself at this point there are
lots of people who are
very confident that joe biden is going
to win there are also very
a lot of people including trump's entire
family who claim that trump has won
they believe trump really won nevada
they believe trump won georgia
they believe trump won pennsylvania they
even believed trump won
michigan and even potentially wisconsin
some of them are saying so
all we can do at this point in time is
wait
in the senate it is increasingly looking
like democrats are not going to take the
senate
now this was my prediction
until very recently at which point i
said there is a path for democrats in
the senate
but you might recall that for the last
three years i've been saying
based on what's up in the senate in 2020
i don't think democrats have a shot my
belief was 2020 has to be the year of
taking
the presidency and 2022 may be the year
of democrats taking the senate
because of some very favorable polling
and the feeling of momentum
over the last couple of months there was
a credible path for democrats to take
the senate
it's conceivable it could happen but it
is not looking particularly likely but a
very interesting senate race
is in georgia in georgia incumbent
republican david perdue
appeared to be winning easily in a
three-way race
most prominently against democratic
challenger john ossoff
as of right now david perdue the
incumbent republican in georgia is
hovering
right at the 50 percent mark in terms of
the vote in georgia
this is relevant because given that it's
a three-way race
if no candidate gets a majority of the
vote meaning if david perdue ends up
with 49.9 percent or 49.8 percent of the
vote
there would be a runoff between purdue
and ossoff the second place
challenger um and that would be a brand
new senate race
and potentially a seat that could be
flipped could be flipped
so we're going to be watching that and
then of course we're also looking at the
numbers in the house
i'm going to tell you right now we don't
have to do it now i am not going to
participate in the stuff of now
as it's looking okay for biden and you
know knock on wood
there are already leftists starting to
criticize joe biden
we're going to take things a step at a
time we'll criticize joe biden if he
becomes president and does things we
don't like
okay we're not getting into that we're
at some point we
will have to have a real um
uh uh not not a maya culpa but a real
accounting
for the problems of the democratic party
is that
um it is pointed to by the house numbers
is the point that i'm making um
many predictions saying oh democrats are
going to dramatically expand their lead
in the house of representatives and uh
it does not yet appear as though that is
happening although
in 2018 we had to wait a little while
for that to be adjudicated but
there is no question that we we have to
be able to hold two
ideas in our head at the same time on
the one hand
yes many trumpists are ignorant yes many
trumpists are uninformed
many are not good people many see
themselves as fighting a war as i said
yesterday where facts don't matter and
they must defend their leader no matter
what
that is true and so part of why
republicans did not get crushed the way
some some predicted
has to do with trumpists but we have to
be able to at the same time say
if the democratic party faced with
arguably the most incompetent president
in the modern political era arguably the
worst
major country responds to the pandemic
in the world
complete mishandling of the economy on
and on and on
if given all of that democrats
end up losing seats in the house
we can't just blame trumpus and that's
exactly how democrats will continue to
lose if they say
it's just stupid trumpus because it's
not it's partially stupid trumpists
the democratic party has responsibility
and we're not going to get ahead of
ourselves but
maybe it'll be tomorrow maybe it'll be
monday
maybe it'll be the following month i
don't know when it's going to be
but i am taking notes i have copious
notes as some like to say
about the failings of the democratic
party
and there will be a time for that so i
know people have started emailing me
saying david why aren't you talking
about this that the other thing about
the
the democratic it's not time yet is it
we do things when there when it is the
time to do it i
i even got emails this morning from
people saying how do you see 2024
no guys no when in 2017 people asked me
about
2020 i said we've got a midterm first we
need to focus on the midterm
we are not even done with this election
yet so we are going to take it a step at
a time as i always insist that we should
be doing glad you're with us today i
will be live later today i hope you will
join me on youtube twitch and facebook
with continued results
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about trump's
lawsuits we will talk about rudy
giuliani and eric trump's stunt
in philadelphia we will talk about
trump's spiritual adviser
um i guess trying to strike out the
demons that may be preventing donald
trump from winning we have all of it
and i want to hear what is on your mind
i am on twitter at deepakman make sure
you're following me there